foreign
let's see hello and welcome to the
academy Museum of Motion Pictures the
largest institution in the United States
devoted to the Arts sciences and artists
of movie making the academy Museum of
Motion Pictures acknowledges the tongva
people as the traditional caretakers of
the water and land in which we program
curate educate convene and discuss we
honor and respect tongva ancestors in
the tongva community today which
continue to nurture this land and water
through traditional practice activism
art and education we also acknowledge
their continued work to safeguard
cultural resources
hi my name is lahani cook she her
pronouns and I am the manager of public
engagement here at the Museum
thank you for joining us in our David
Geffen Theater for the animated feature
film nominee panel presented as a part
of our Oscars week programming
before we before we begin the panel
public programming for the 2023 Oscar
week is made possible by the Ruderman
Family Foundation which provokes which
promotes authentic representation in the
entertainment industry and full
inclusion of people with disabilities
throughout all sectors of society
I would like to thank our ASL
interpreters who will be assisting today
their names are hafid salceda felix Via
Real and Paola Morales now please help
me in welcome to the stage senior vice
president of member relations Global
Outreach and and awards Administration
Tom oyer
hello hi everybody great to see you all
um I'm here representing Our member
relations and awards Administration team
for today I want to thank you for all
joining and you need to know a lot more
about these five nominated animated
feature films so you might ask how did
how did we get here how do these films
how do these nominations come into play
so I want to just give a little overview
of our process and how we get to this
point first step is that films need to
qualify first in order to be eligible
for consideration in order to qualify
it's based on a theatrical qualifying
release that all these films all films
submitted films have their theatrical
release in order to qualify the Second
Step then is the films need to be
submitted in order to be considered for
Academy consideration uh this year we
received 27 submissions for the animated
feature film category films from all
over the world I want to make sure to
give a special thank you to Michael
Benedict Lauren McPhee and many of the
others on our Academy team who help so
much with all the submission process
without them the category in this
process wouldn't exist
um yeah all right yes thank you
[Applause]
um so then the next step once we get all
our submissions then we have our voting
process so then we go through the
process of making our films available to
our voting members in this category in
particular
all members of the short films and
feature animation Branch are eligible
automatically eligible to vote in this
category additionally we also in sent
out an invitation to all other Academy
members and other branches if they want
to participate and opt in to vote in the
category by opting in then they are then
given a certain assignment of certain
number of films as we need to view in
order to be eligible to vote through
that process we have a number of members
all over the world participate in the
voting process the members then vote
these members are the ones that then
vote to determine the five nominees that
you have today then the next step which
just finished we have then the entire
Academy membership then votes on the
winner in all 23 categories which just
ended yesterday so we shall see on
Sunday what goes what happens from there
then uh I want to be take this moment to
really thank all the academy members who
participate in this process throughout
the year it is a lot of work we keep you
very busy I know and we really genuinely
very much appreciate all your help so
thank you next I would like to introduce
to you the short films of feature
animation Branch chair
um she is in her fifth year as an
academy Governor she's a two-time
Academy award-nominated producer and a
wonderful partner to work with year
round please welcome Bonnie Arnold
[Applause]
the short people version okay
um welcome everybody it's so good to see
everyone this evening I know you're in
for a really fun time with a lot of
great filmmakers tonight so welcome all
of you on behalf of the governors of the
short film and feature animation Branch
myself John Bloom and Marlon West and
it's just so great to be having this
event at our beautiful Museum we are so
proud and again it's great to have you
here I just want to have a shout out
thank you to the academy and the museum
staff for making this event possible
tonight
um so without further Ado I want to
introduce the moderator for this evening
it's Marlon West who is our newest
governor of our Branch he for the past
30 years he has been an animator and uh
effects head of effects and visual
effects supervisor at Disney at Walt
Disney feature Animation Studios his
credits include some of our most beloved
and memorable films from from Disney The
Lion King Pocahontas Hunchback Hercules
Tarzan Fantasia Princess and the Frog
Frozen Moana and can't just to name a
few anyway Marlin is very accomplished
and we're excited to have him be
moderating tonight's panel so without
further Ado I want to introduce my
friend and colleague Marlon West
thanks Bonnie and she's already set it
up for the fun size folks so thank you
sister
um you can see all these chairs up here
do we have a big big panel and I want to
get going as soon as possible so we can
get them all um we can get some
knowledge and insights from all of them
so I want to thank you all myself for
being here I'm like super excited to uh
meet and hang out with all these folks
and talk about these wonderful wonderful
films but first i'm going to before I'll
bring out the nominees I want to bring
out the uh ALS interpreters who are
going to take a seat up here with us
thanks a lot
so as Bonnie mentioned I've been at the
in the animation racket for a minute and
um animators we don't get a whole lot of
hype and you know as we work very much
behind the scenes so I'm going to bring
out these folks with this much much love
and hype as I can if you want to bring
them out with some love please do so I'm
going to start off
with first time nominee Lindsey Collins
and two-time nominee and not in a
Academy Award winner Tommy she for
turning red
yeah that's right thank you
[Applause]
this is his first nomination
and along with him is Chris Williams
this is his third nomination and he's an
Academy Award winner for Big Hero 6. we
bring out the big filmmakers of Sea
Beast
so this is the first not first
nominations for both Joel Crawford and
Mark Swift can bring out the creators of
Puss in Boots
first nominations for
Elizabeth home curl and chaplain and
Paul mizzi
and could you please bring out the
creators and nominees for Marcel the
show with shoes on
this is the first nomination for Mark
Gustafson
Gary Unger and Alex Buckley
and this is
the six-time nominee in the Academy
Award winner Gail Mel del Toro could you
please bring out the nominees for Gail
Mo del Toro's Pinocchio please
[Applause]
all right so I'm I'm super excited to be
sitting up in here because I'm a big fan
of all of these films I've seen them all
multiple times some of these folks I've
known for a long time personally I won't
say how long and and some folks have
been a fan of and heard speak and and
seen their films for a long time so
um I I couldn't be more excited to be
sitting here in this this seat right now
and as a person who's been in the
animation racket for a minute I know for
a fact the animation takes a long time
it's a big labor of love so a film with
a whole studio behind it
it's about five years to get a film from
your head in your heart onto the screen
and one of the things I know about these
five beautiful films is that there's
some struggle involved in getting all of
them made from long gestation periods to
having to go someplace to let you make
it to convincing someone that your point
of view matters
so I'm going to go down starting with
with my folks from turning red and and I
started starting with our directors and
my next question is going to be towards
our producers
to describe um their experience did it
what it took to get this film from their
head and heart into the screen
yeah
turning red uh started in in 2017 after
I had finished my short film bow which
was about a mother
um and like getting over her empty nest
syndrome with with her son in the form
of a dumpling and then I realized after
making the short that hmm I still have a
lot to process in my relationship with
my mom like a whole feature film's worth
of of therapy to go through uh and so uh
when I when Pixar approached me and
asked me to pitch three ideas for a
feature film uh turning red uh was the
most I think personal and the weirdest
and I think that's what Drew picks are
to it because in this very super
specific story about this Chinese
Canadian girl going through magical
puberty and fighting with her mom and
her horniness and her love of boy bands
they found this really Universal story
about
um this uh kid who is just experiencing
the messiness of growing up of her
emotions out of control of her body out
of control and
um and I think that yeah that's that's
what they were drawn to but uh yeah it
was it was definitely a huge shift from
directing a Shore to a feature uh it's
90 minutes and also it was tricky for me
personally too because I hadn't had that
own resolution with my own mom so the
ending didn't come until maybe the
eighth screening but um yeah but it was
such an amazing experience to be able to
work with Lindsay Collins and this
entire team of female leadership and we
made something that I'm so proud of so
yeah
[Applause]
hey I guess I'm next
um yeah Marlon and I go way back I
worked at Disney animation for 25 years
and and I left primarily um because I
want to change for change sake but I
also wanted to tell this story The Sea
Beast I want to tell a story that
tonally would feel like the ones that I
love the most uh growing up uh when I
was a kid I loved the big action
adventure uh genre stories so I loved
King Kong it was like my favorite movie
when I was a kid of course Star Wars uh
but Raiders of the Lost Ark was a big
lightning bolt moment for me I remember
very vividly the experience of watching
the movie I remember of course loving
everything about it but also being
cognizant of the fact that adults made
this thing and it was a strangely
reassuring moment for me because I
realized I realized as I was having this
internal conversation that it's okay I
can grow up and not let go of all the
things that I love as a kid and it made
me want to make movies and tell stories
and so I wanted to make an action
adventure genre film that would
hopefully sort of capture some of the
spirit of the movies that I love the
most growing up and so I I presented
something to Netflix and they were
excited about it
um but you mentioned the the hardship
part of it and and I'll say that the
first set of story reels that we put up
they were terrible like it just didn't
work and but that's nothing new you know
every first set of story Wheels I've
ever put up has never been any good but
it's an incredible tool you learn so
much from it and there are there's good
within it and so we just we were willing
to we were able to throw out most of it
and and persevere and find the movie
that was that was out there and and
finally were able to sort of put
together a movie that I'm really proud
of
[Applause]
um yeah the uh Puss in Boots
um
I'm haven't you reminded of something
Guillermo said of
um then and I'm just quoting you garmo
so uh you have so many quotable things I
love it um but the something you said of
um the natural state of a movie is not
to be made is that right I get that
right
um but that like it's so true in it's
like whether it's animation whether it's
live action you're the this big
undertaking of telling a story and it
takes so many people to create this kind
of unified vision and when we came on to
Puss and Boots
um
it had been through multiple iterations
it'd been
um you know over 10 years since the
first movie and the studio it was this
nugget of an idea of like
of a Puss in Boots on his last of his
nine lives and I think for us
we had to figure out
like why are we making this why is it
relevant now after a decade
um why is it a fairy tale for our time
and I think the thing that we kind of
grabbed on to is
the premise is absurd it's about a cat
on its ninth life it feels like a fairy
tale
but when we boiled it down
it was this is about we have one life
Puss and Boots realizes he has one life
and how are you going to spend it
um who are you going to spend it with
and when we found that nugget and really
said
the only way to do this is to really
tell the story forget that it's a sequel
like forget that it's animation it's
like the the normal kind of themes and
that you might expect in animation
you're not going to talk about death
well I guess this year we are
we have multiple
um but but that we really knew we had to
in order to feel a joyful celebration of
life by the end of the movie go to a
dark place with kind of inspiration from
Grim fairy tales and I think that was
part of our the challenge was this is
still a comedy it's still an adventure
um but it's going to go to some uh kind
of challenging uh subject matter and how
we address that and so we had to rework
a lot and really kind of find it
together but um I mean the the studio
was right there with us every step of
the way so it was a great experience
[Applause]
um I guess I will speak for our
wonderful director Dean Fleischer Camp
who's very sorry you couldn't be here
today he's uh shooting uh Owen prep on
the live action Lilo and Stitch in
Hawaii which is very exciting can't wait
to see that
um but we will try and and do him
Justice uh you know I think the well
also I just have to say it's totally
surreal and incredible to be on a panel
with you all and I'm a huge fan of all
of your work and your films and it's
crazy that we get to share space with
you and thank you for telling your
stories
um Marcel and we are sort of the
red-headed step shell of newbies on the
Block who like crawled in through the
dryer vent and like took honey
Footprints down to even be here so this
is wild
um an answer to your question uh there
were a lot of really interesting
challenges in
um the creation of Marcel I mean you
know uh for folks who don't know Jenny
uh slate and Dean Fleischer Camp
co-created the character of Marcel in
2010 in a very adorable idiosyncratic
stop-motion animated short film they
went on to make three shorts and two New
York Times best-selling children's books
and I can say that as their unofficial
publicist
um but the feature was a long road and a
lot of you know questions that we often
got
um we're like yeah the shorts are cute
but how are you going to sustain this
for 90 minutes
um and also for me as a producer coming
from the live action world I often was
told independent stop-motion animation
is not a thing like in the future space
it like if you're not backed by Pixar or
DreamWorks or now Netflix
this isn't really gonna happen
um and how are you going to put this
together and of course we were able to
build this incredible team led by our
animation director Kirsten lapore and
the Kyoto brothers and and the huge
Incredible Crew
um and we found great Partners in uh the
non-profit Centereach um which is where
I met Carolina Palm my fellow producers
um but you know Centereach really were
the ones who who believed in us trying
to retain the authenticity of Marcel
something that was really important to
Jenny and Dean from the beginning was
that Marcel even though he's a tiny
shell
feels incredibly human he is incredibly
human and has so much heart and depth
and complexity
um and how do you retain that and how
could we tell a story that didn't
necessarily go big it wasn't like a
lunchbox musical
um but that could go deeper and that
might have more in common with gray
Gardens than some of some of the other
bigger animated films out there and so
it was really this this Balancing Act of
and this challenge of how do we retain
what we love about Marcel
um and how can we find the right
Partners who believe in US telling this
story this way and this you know
somewhat improvised documentary style
approach to stop motion
um that was hard to kind of comp because
it was really its own thing
um so
that took many years to kind of figure
out how to how to put together and make
the version of the film you see today
[Applause]
well I think I'll probably let my
co-director speak to the origins of of
this project but I'll say that one of
the one of the first challenges was
why do it why tell this story again and
everybody knows Pinocchio you know what
do we have to say that's new about it
and ultimately
the approach that Guillermo and Patrick
the co-writer took to this was what
really attracted me they said no we're
gonna what we're gonna do is this is not
about a wooden boy trying to become a
real boy
this is not a story about trying to be
good and perfect and then being rewarded
for it
and they kind of refocused the story
almost on Geppetto more than Pinocchio
in a way and made it about a father
learning to be a good father
um you'll notice in the film that
Pinocchio doesn't change very much
he's born into the world you know he's
naked and he's unfinished
like many of us really and he that's how
he goes through the world and and the
world has to accept him everyone he
touches
changes because he's this figure who
just asked why he's very disruptive
because he's in a world where everybody
is
Marching In lockstep he's like he simply
asked why
and and that seems like that seems
revolutionary
in the moment
so um
I think
there were other many many challenges
for you know big things in terms of the
production and stuff but I have to say
all stop-motion films are just what seem
almost impossible when you start them
and and this year has been an amazing
year for stop motion I mean
with uh Marcel
incredible that I mean it's amazing that
you guys could make that movie
um we had um Wendell and wild from Henry
Selleck
we have Mad God from Phil Tippett so I
as a as a year for stop motion this was
incredible and I think it's it bodes
well for the future that these
completely different viewpoints I mean
none of those films are even remotely
like the other which is really exciting
to me
well every single time I've made a movie
has been because the idea is
irresistible and suicidal I I've never
I've never been able to think of a
normal movie that's really I mean if I'm
working even on the most commercial
Arena I have to pick up the one nobody
wants to do I I really am used to it
I try to push as much as much as I can I
always say when I'm making a movie I'm a
Sisyphus when I'm promoting it I'm
Cassandra I'm saying no don't do that in
the marketing please don't it up
and they always it up you know but
that is definition of what we do and
that's what we do this is how the
sandwich comes and we're going to change
it but it is only because I don't want
to make movies that have been done I
don't want to make movies that sound
reasonable I don't want to do a movie
that
will appeal to a certain quadrant or an
audience for me I don't have a
filmography I have a biography
and each of those movies
are movies that
I've been willing to die for and with my
weight that's your reality you know I
really think about them about why
there's images or moments that sustain
me through the hardships and I'm then
like John Candy and plane Trains and
Automobiles I have a a suitcase full of
shower rings and depending on the client
I always am promoting when shower ring
or the other the movies are never dead
for me until I go and they're always
dormant I have over 30 screen please I
have a written or got written and I have
only done 12 movies so that means there
are 20 shower rings in the suitcase and
every time I meet with someone I pull
out the oldest moldiest showering and I
go what about this one
took over my half of my career to get
made and you know all it takes is one
person that says yes unfortunately the
definition the main Paradox of our
business is the people with the money
money look back
to the land on the ship and we look
forward to a destiny that we haven't
arrived at
so we are in the same ship in absolutely
mutinous oppositional circumstances and
that will never change and that is
actually I think good because adversity
is the path the obstacle is the path
when when the more resistance you have
to an idea the more you have to think
it's going to be good because these
don't want to make it and and
and and and it really I it's come to the
point where I I find it as stimulating
so
that's about that's about a good
definition of how hard it was to get
people the things
the things that make a beauty mark are
seen as a mold for years and years in
other words the things that make
Pinocchio the beautiful thing it is were
exactly the reasons why it was turned
down
because it dealt with disobedience it
dealt with not changing to be loved and
it was everybody died and it was during
the rise of Mussolini and and those
sound great like great ideas to me
absolutely you see why this brother's so
quotable
and we we're keeping it 100 here in the
Geffen Theater you know so okay
um so I'm gonna direct this one to uh to
our producers
um so I I think all of these films were
made during during the kovitz and
um and and and let's talk about because
you know the film I'm working the
project I'm working on I've been working
on a zoom screen uh on three continents
um for the last two and a half years and
but I'd like to go down and start with
Lindsay and and hear about how
covet affected these uh these projects
um
our first sequence locked for animation
on Friday
then it was it the 9th of March I think
the sixth is that right like everything
shut down on the Monday so we were we
were literally in editorial trying to
lock something to launch it into
animation our first sequence
and we were kind of hearing whispers and
closing the door and not opening it was
like nobody opened the door because I
think they're going to tell us we have
to go home and
um so we we basically finished and then
locked it and went home like everybody
else
um and then found out we weren't going
back and were delusional for several
months where we're like it's about it's
right around the corner we're almost
back we're almost gonna be back
um and it was pretty incredible actually
I I
um I say this in retrospect but um
having been at Pixar for 26 years almost
um it felt a lot like the early days in
a weird way it was such a it was such a
leveling of the playing field and for
the first time nobody knew what they
were doing and all of the experience
that some of us had built over the years
and that kind of sense of like all right
I know what we're doing we got this like
we know how we're gonna make this film
was gone
um and there was a certain kind of
joy in that to some degree because it
forced a vulnerability everybody was
like I have no idea what I'm doing I
don't know how this is going to work I
don't know how my family is going to
work during this whole thing
um and it also forced a vulnerability
because we all saw the mess of
everybody's lives
um I famously God uh yeah you already
know what I'm gonna say
um I in a recording session recording
session with actors my kids start
fighting in the other room and I was
like I pull out my airpods put in my
hands storm into the other room and like
lay into them I'm swearing I'm like God
damn it like in my I think my daughter
had her arm clocked back and my son was
like ah like and it was and I walk back
I like lose it completely I walk back in
and I put the airlines back in and he's
like um we just heard all of that and I
was like what and apparently if you hold
your airpods in your hand real close to
your ears they don't actually they don't
shut off they think it's your anyway fun
fact
um so there was a lot of that and it was
super I actually have to say that our
crew was so I think we were so grateful
for each other frankly every morning
getting up and getting to laugh and
getting to see each other and complain
and having our kids sitting on our laps
while we're you know reviewing shots it
just there was something about it that
as horrible as it was it did bring it
back to what it felt like at the very
beginning in the sense that we were just
kind of in chaos and there is something
that's kind of beautiful about that to
some degree and I think you I think you
see it on the screen I think it's
special and I think it translated
somehow
um I I agree with Lindsay I think our
experience is actually quite similar I
mean I I think for us I what I realized
later on really upon reflection is the
that the movie kind of became a refuge
actually for a lot of us and all the
craziness of the world all the craziness
the flipping and educating our families
and our children like in in the house
while you're trying to do your work
um and it was you know we had a lot of
laughs and all that is true but like to
to be connected with people and to be
talking and be talking about work and
talking about the film that we were all
so dedicated and pushing so hard on
um I I think for us it was a it was a it
was totally like a buoying factor in our
lives and uh and I know it was for
myself and and ironically another thing
that I thought was amazing about this is
that I've been working in animation for
more than 20 years and this is the most
behind the scenes my children have ever
seen of any movie I've ever worked on
was to sit in my bedroom where my office
is and watch Chris direct actors on
screen or come and see animation dailies
right come and see an art review I mean
that's stuff that like I talk to them
about for years but to see it and to see
it and to see get to see Chris work and
get to see Chris ask questions and think
it's like man that's that's invaluable
stuff that was incredible for them
actually and uh so I for me like this
movie was already going to be one of the
most difficult things I think I've ever
tried to do and in the pandemic I was
like oh my God like did this just get
harder and and it totally Did But like
everyone buckled down everyone was like
okay but this is what we all have to do
together and and they did it and uh from
the Netflix Team to the Sony Pictures
image Works team we couldn't have asked
for more it was incredible really
I think we were in a little bit of a
different boat just because of timing so
we finished crude's a new age together
we worked on that movie which came out
in 2019 I think 2020 and that was kind
of finished in the covert time and um
you know it was a real bummer actually
having a movie uh finish and then not
have all the things that we normally
have like wrap parties and celebrations
and having to do yeah and so
um we rolled on to uh put some boots in
early
21. so as Joel said the the movie had
had a couple of false starts and so we
were sort of already got into the cycle
of working you know remotely but we had
to move very very fast on the movie
people talk about typically there's I
don't know four years that you have to
make a movie we came on a movie we had
less than half that time and so one of
the things we quickly decided because we
effectively we had to come up with uh
what we wanted the story to be and then
make that movie we we didn't have the
time to iterate that we might and there
was Joel and me and Daniel the
co-director who's kind of hanging out
there and the editor and our writer Paul
and I had a story Heidi and we had some
production support and we quickly
decided that it sucked trying to figure
out what the movie was
um doing it remotely and we would
actually go back to work and we were the
first people back at DreamWorks and it
was really weird because it was us in
the janitorial staff every day and you
know we used to all these free food and
these great things at DreamWorks there
was none of it you know
um but there was something about you
know
um actually being together in a room
talking that um really helped and um and
even though not you know and it was kind
of split there was still a lot of people
working from home there's still a lot of
people working from home I think it's
changed the way that we work permanently
um a lot of people have relocated and
you know were before we'd say there was
never a chance an animator there had to
be in the studio that's work now those
people there's people who have moved all
over the US and internationally and they
work but I think for us when we were
trying to find that movie we felt
actually being together in a room
in person enabled us to move faster so
we were kind of lucky we came up
starting to come up on the other side of
it
[Applause]
I'll just say something and then I'll
pass it to Paul but I think for us
because the story of Marcel is literally
about somebody who's missing their
community and so isolated it was
um and the whole time we were with
Marcel I know we all were loved him so
much and loved the story so much and
felt so much like we couldn't wait for
this shell to be shared with everybody
and it just took on so much more meaning
really throughout the the pandemic and
knowing that and we really believe that
on the other side of it when people saw
it it was so beautiful to have them
connect with that story and I think it
really opened up a lot of deeper
conversations that it might not have on
that major level so it just gave so much
love to like everyone else is saying
here and it really created our community
so strongly but also I think we all felt
and everyone that worked on it in all
the iterations like it was really gonna
give something happy and positive and
beautiful to to other people and in many
ways it sustained us I think the pure
his Purity and his vision and his
you know sincerity and and how much he
just fiercely held on to the his
grandmother and also wanting to see his
family and finding the joy in everyday
life really I think spoke to us and
helped sustain us so
yeah and when when we um
we had already shot all the live-action
plates and and it just geared up the
entire like stages for the animation and
we're like in the early weeks of the
animation when
when the you know covid was sort of
percolating but nobody really knew what
was going on and there was no guidance
on what to do and I just remember you
know getting all this information from
everywhere about what is actually going
on and how dangerous is this and how
long is it and can you die and
um we started having
um taking it sort of day by day and
doing surveys with we had a very
intimate small team we were only had 10
stages in a very small space
um and so we ended up like making having
group conversations about what the plan
should be and and we made a collective
decision to shut down at some point and
it was a really complicated decision but
because everyone's voice was in the room
making that decision together it felt
like we all owned it and um and it
actually brought the team extremely
close and so we had done a few weeks of
Animation we shut down and we didn't
know if we would be able to come back up
or win and at first it was like oh maybe
it's a couple weeks and then went on
into months
and then I think people began to get
concerned that we were never going to
finish this movie that we had spent
years and years on and we had no Studio
behind us we had limited funds nobody
could get paid during the Hiatus we
begged the stage to forego our rent and
just leave all our sets up because I
couldn't rebuild we couldn't and then we
were tracking
um the code you remember those charts
where things are like you know it's like
hospitalizations infections and they're
like they're like these waves it's
almost like surfing and and we saw this
downward Trend like in the middle of the
summer and we sort of went back and
started all talking among our crew about
what do we do what do we do and and we
decided to go back and everyone got to
vote on that and we went back right when
it was like in August and and the wave
was coming down and literally we were
able to finish our final I think it was
seven weeks of Animation between the
wave going down and right when it
started peeking up again in October and
like somehow we were like blessed in
this moment and
um yeah and I think it just it really
brought us close together and for the in
the film and then it felt
um everyone was extremely diligent that
we didn't know what the protocols were
going to be but we kind of
um propose certain rules and and for the
whole crew and then everyone really
diligently like participated in mapping
out a plan to to be safe and obviously
because our stages are isolated a bit we
it was easier logistically than it might
be and also our crew was super small but
um I I think it brought everyone
together and then the residents like
Caroline was saying about what we were
making and sort of the thematics of the
film really started percolating becoming
real and one thing that struck me is at
the end we were doing the credits the
crawl of the film and we understood that
some people had passed you know during
this period and we were going to put in
in memory of a few people and then we
started reaching out to the crew to see
if there was anyone else
and it was shocking but I didn't end up
being a dozen names that and and we
realized not all of them were directly
linked to covid but during that that
period how many people had passed and a
lot of it due to covet and then I think
the film itself became the film is about
moving on from grief and loss and I
think it became very personal for the
for the whole team and that sort of
realization of how many people had
experienced actual loss during that
period of making this film I'm really
really struck home
thank you
yeah well uh kovid was a real thing from
Pinocchio
um we
were about a year into it
um and uh like everyone else I think
there was that moment uh you know you
had sort of a three-day plan what's
going to happen and and you know it
quickly escalated
um and uh you know this was
a a you know a moment for the crew uh to
show what they're made of right so this
is a crew we actually never shut down
uh everyone went home to their
uh you know houses Apartments uh they
went into their basements they went into
their uh extra rooms they went into
their backyards and continued
fabricating so in stop motion is is many
of you may not know it's you know these
are these are physical fabrication
moments where you're making props you're
making puppets you're making sets the
entire team we had just started shooting
so only a few frames had gone up onto
stages
and out this crew went into their homes
and continued to solder in barbecues I
went into their basement and continued
painting props and other elements and
the shutdown was for us maybe about
eight to ten weeks but just the
fortitude the resilience the creative
out of box thinking that sort of brought
this team together and another you know
uh you know aspect of stop motion is
it's not you know just sort of one
person isolated by themselves it may
seem that way in those dark stages but
uh it takes you know a lot of people
moving around each other
all day throughout the days this then
became a moment where we were you know
uh socially distancing each other within
this huge Studio space up in Portland
Oregon
and it became
uh I don't know sort of a mantra of
safety production suddenly meant
something other than just you know
budgets and schedule became sort of a a
place to take care of each other a place
to get information
and that
level of communication under the most
dire of circumstances uh had I think
like every film here had a real positive
impact ultimately on what ended up on
screen
um you know I I can't say that it was
better worse but I I know that uh as a
crew as a production and as a team
with the incredible support of you know
Netflix and just the whole apparatus
uh worked out pretty well he thinks did
you want to add or I just I do want to
say that Alex is sitting in Portland we
were all scattered different places and
Alex soldiered through and every week
we'd have a producer's call and he would
report back and how many kova tests how
many and
hard enough to produce some of these
films to begin with and having to cope
with that on top of it was extraordinary
so we really made it through and he led
the way so thank you
thank you all
[Applause]
some very moving tellings
um so you know as an effects artist
which is what I've been most of my
career and you know visual effects an
animated feature is a bunch of stuff
that usually uh is everything but but
the character themselves so it's you
know smoke fire rain so like it's the
kind of thing that people don't usually
comment on like oh man when Mufasa fell
to his death
that dust cloud got kicked up when he
landed
bought it to me like you know no one's
ever said that
um so um
I was just going to ask a very nerdy
question because you know I'm holding
the mic
so um
I'd just like to to in in anyone from
each production can answer this but
there's all I know there's technical
hurdles
um
you know you all just got a psychic
award for you know being able to laser
print you know very very thin uh Mac
hats for uh armatures for for your film
and then I'm sure there's some some um
very kind of down and dirty kind of
techniques that were you know used to do
some of the other films so um can we
just kind of go down and maybe we'll
we'll start with turning red and like
what were some of the either
technical or
or uh creative hurdles that you had to
get through to get this your particular
uh
vision
well I'll start I mean I think
um Domi actually had a very specific
style she was going for at the beginning
and it was kind of in some ways counter
to if you will the house style of Pixar
it was not as kind of realistic or
nuanced it was much more kind of pushed
and held if you will
um which is you know it's not as though
you know there's not a bunch of people
who are fans of that or know how to do
that in-house but it's not something I
think we have leaned into certainly
um and you know we we had a lot of
debates we were like all right we're
gonna do you know we're gonna animate on
twos and threes and there was a lot of
like oh great and everybody's super
excited we don't know how to render on
Tuesday I mean it was like all this
technology that turns out it's quite
difficult to do things simpler
um and uh and so we went down that path
um and we kind of got these cool tests
done and stuff and pulled in Pete doctor
and
um showed him and you know he was he was
great he was like I tote and it's
interesting for him I think because
usually
um kind of in the past you know I think
he's been the one that tends to push
things
um visually and and John Lasseter was
the one that was always kind of like
well not too far we kind of bring him
back and so it was this bizarre feeling
I think for Pete to all of a sudden be
on the side where he was like why are we
why are we pushing it that far I mean it
was kind of like he hated himself a
little bit
um but I think he was really great
because he said you know look as long as
there's a reason for it I'm in like as
long as you guys can come up with a
great reason for why you're doing it not
just because it's cool or because it's
new or because you want to like why does
the story demand it why does the
character demand it then I think that's
the key you got to talk about it from
that standpoint and he kind of let us go
back and really think think hard about
why we were going for that look and why
you wanted to do it and come up with a
great
um kind of argument for it really and um
and I think you know in doing so he
really helped Domi certainly and and our
production designer and stuff get really
good about talking about the why because
it's so much easier for your crew of 200
people who are all coming on from
different shows with different you know
kind of backgrounds to sit down and have
an understanding of why we're pushing
something one way or why is the color
choice that and it was all very much
about well we're kind of talking about
if this 13 year old girl was she's the
director she's she production designed
it what colors does she love
um you know it's the first time we have
a Pixar character who introduces herself
to camera at the beginning and it's like
what would her music be what would she
want her music to be her score her theme
and the minute we started talking about
that and about kind of how the
stylization came from that
um it just made it easier everybody got
it
um and so in in kind of giving us his
his reluctant pushback
um I think Pete did a really great job
of getting us to think a little deeper
as to the why behind the looks and and
um as a result I think you kind of it
feels cohesive when you watch it
so that was one cool thanks
great
um yeah I think the term we coined was
Asian tween fever dream and uh that was
kind of the look and the style that we
were going for from the beginning
because our main character is Mei Lee
She's this energetic uh you know Chinese
Canadian girl and um I grew up watching
anime I was vice president of the anime
club in high school so my not not
president that's too much responsibility
I was vice president
um and so my artistic and animation
influences draw from anime as much as it
does from Western cartoons and it just
felt like the like the perfect kind of
mishmash of eastern and western
animation styles to tell the story about
this girl that's caught between like
eastern and western uh worlds and yeah
it was tricky because like half of the
animators didn't grow up with anime
didn't know like when to use the Starry
Eyes for the the character or like why
you know they would suddenly be like
covered in beads of sweat so it was it's
like when we developed the pitch Bible
no the the animation style guide uh for
for the show that we actually actually
had to like sit down and break down like
the anime style and kind of explain that
to the animators which is really cool so
yeah
[Applause]
um well there's a lot of ropes in this
movie The Giant boat there's a huge
amount of water I mean going into this
movie uh having come off actually uh
quite a large movie before this that had
a lot of water and big creatures
um I even with this one I was like I
don't know man I'm not sure we can do
this we had a full crew of people on the
boat uh we had monsters in the water and
water and ropes and everybody moving and
everything and I would I I there was a
lot of me that was like I kind of needed
to see it a little bit to understand if
like could we pull all this stuff off
and I I was I was like Blown Away
frankly and I was I was always amazed at
like whatever we would come up with or
what was represented in the board or in
previous there was never really like a
no it was never came to a no it was
always like that's very cool it let us
kind of think about what we can do do
and I think that was the spirit that we
approached a lot of this movie with and
and I think it it shows in because it
feels like it's this amazing immersive
world but it also has this magic quality
and I think the the real uh sort of look
of the effects mixed with the animation
Style mixed with the boat and and the
backgrounds it's like it it did create
something that people hadn't lived in
and been in before and I and I think all
of those things add up to that and all
all of it adds to the movie itself so
this guy uh yeah everything in this
movie was hard I don't recommend
anything that we did in this movie uh
lots of water lots of ropes it was we
and we worked with Sony image Works in
Vancouver and they had lots of this
movie is going to be hard meetings and
they were kind of but they were prepared
for it
um the one of the things that I was
really uh sort of that hadn't that I
didn't consider going in
um was the fact that not only are we
gonna have to deal with all the water
but the fact that our characters are on
ships and boats that are on the water
and being affected by the water we
always have this water simulation
affecting the ship and but we couldn't
ask the animators to counter animate
that constantly so they had to work out
a technology where the characters their
knees and their hips would always be
adjusting to the shifting of the ship so
that's that's one of those things where
there are lots of geniuses that are
smarter than us that get ahead of these
things you know and so we definitely
benefited from that and the probably the
one the last thing to to conquer for us
that again I didn't really consider was
the sales themselves and the sales and
the ships when they filled with wind
that was the technical challenge that
they didn't get ahead of to the extent
that they they were even surprised by it
the folks that were that were making the
movie at in Vancouver and and so we were
fairly late in the game when they were
like oh we're not sure we're gonna get
this movie done and and uh because they
couldn't make this the sales fill
convincingly and there's there's one
shot that is very near and dear to my
heart because they finally in this one
wide shot out of the ship got the sales
to work and at that moment we knew we'd
passed all the hurdles anything all the
obstacles were out of our way now we can
just make the movie so that was probably
the final challenge for us
unfurling and feeling it's very hard
never do that so um
thank you
so the folks on stage here can see these
two green lights and you weren't
informed before but that's a 10 minute
warning
um I could talk to these folks all night
but um so
just I'll pick let everybody know
can I say the quest
the quest about
the the different kind of innovative
techniques
I don't think there could have been a
better year to ask that question than
all of the movies on this stage like
seriously now I feel really insightful
thank you well I mean it's cool because
it's like I when I saw CBS I was like
blown away like how did they do that
with with yeah just the technical aspect
but the cinematography that that
integrated with it
um the influence of of anime which we
also uh dipped into the all the stop
motion but that is it's so unique and
even a film that this that had to be
questioned whether it's animation or not
like that animation is everything it's
it's it can tell any story and it can be
told anyway and
um so I just think
um preach
it's just exciting like asking that
question and getting such unique answers
um
I mean for us it's funny I was also part
of the the nerdy uh kids who were into
anime which isn't the case anymore
when I was a stream now it's mainstream
it's cool
um when I was a kid I was I probably I
don't know how old I was a young kid and
I saw Akira the 1988 Akira
um which blew my mind and it was like
this thing is epic and the dust clouds
and everything I actually was like
trying to draw those shapes and like
um that influenced us in a big way we
kind of had two kind of visual
Inspirations
um
our production designer Nate rag Helm
this idea that what if Puss in Boots
look like it was dropped into a fairy
tale painting So we had this painterly
style
um and then in execution we thought it'd
be great once again like
you do stuff that you think is cool but
you have a reason behind it and for us
the idea that we're telling a story
about Puss in Boots who is essentially
living a fairy tale he thinks he's
Immortal he's Invincible
um and then he gets kind of woken up to
mortality
um
we use the painterly style to feel like
the audience has dropped right in you're
enjoying this ride with him
and even a stepped animation style where
that's really leaned into the fun of of
anime references
um that feels Fantastical feels turned
up it doesn't feel grounded and that's
his point of view and then in moments
which are puss experiencing you know joy
and connection or vulnerability and fear
then we use the the traditional kind of
CG like everything on ones and and you
can feel when it switches up and
I think that's what it just excites me
about
what animation continues doing where as
a director who's telling a story
it feels like we've been given more
tools to to tell a more specific story
and I think
um you know it's not easy it's kind of
like you're discovering your own like
language as you're going because of the
you're you're making up the vocabulary
there are times where we were in the the
theater and we thought we were looking
at viz Dev paintings and it was the
actual lighting of the movie and so it
was a crazy ride but um an exciting one
super cool thanks
I know where green light limited on time
so uh I will I will just sort of echo
everything was hard everything was
technically wild
um this whisper campaign we've left
behind us about whether or not our movie
was animated
um speaks to this feeling of
um the film being seamless it was
incredibly important to Dean and Kirsten
um to make Marcel feel like he really
exists in the real world at the
marcellian scale in the real world that
he's in a real documentary which
included a lot of handheld
cinematography in natural lighting we
often talk about the car shot of Marcel
you know on top of the dashboard you can
tell I'm a New Yorker because I'm like
what's that thing called in the car
um where the where the light it you know
where natural light is just Pat car buys
the natural light and palm trees and
everything we're passing him by and how
did we recreate and replicate that
lighting the natural lighting Source uh
on to the animation stages we had to do
with every single element of this film
all the Real World objects had to be
translated and replicated and animated
and so our animators were not only
animating Marcel and Connie and the many
other characters in the film they're
also animating seemingly inanimate
objects and the interactions had to seem
seamless and and real
so that I mean on a technical level I
think just the the attention to detail
down to the down to the speck of dust in
the air
um was really a feat of the team that
were incredibly I'm still astonished by
it and so proud of
cool cool
but by the way
I'm not so worried about them lights
they can kick us out of here
well I think that
we had so many things that would be
entertaining to discuss about technical
solving you know I think we we had to
our direct the animation on bfx to match
the stop-motion the uh you know the
printing of the puppets Etc but I think
uh when we started talking about it I
think the decisions we made that are
important actually went counter we went
we looked back
and we decided and most of the puppets
needed to be manually controlled and not
printed faces
because we thought uh you know you won
the sacred moment between the animator
and the puppet not to be now phase 211 b
c Part B uh you want for the animator to
move the the eyebrow move the mouth and
have that Exquisite beautiful thing that
stop-motion gives you which is
transmitting your soul to the puppet to
give an animal animate and that was one
and the second one is not a technical
technical we did a lot Frank passing
them or cinematographer he's a genius
everybody in the puppet making in the
animation brilliant but
the greatest thing was to tell the
animators you are not technicians your
cast
your actors your Superstars and we will
credit you like that and treat you like
that and we went to the animators and
said encourage improvisation the other
thing that we did is if the puppet wants
to do something follow the puppet ignore
an instruction try weird things do
unnecessary moves and ultimately this
the accelerate animation because we talk
about animation is not a genre for kids
it's a animation in cinema but the
rhythms of it are condition to
be sitcom and they're conditioned to be
this screwball rhythms with one-liners
and a vocabulary of almost Emoji things
and and what I love about the movies
that are selected this year is each of
them explores this in a different way
not only technically but for expression
none of the movies is going for eye
candy they're going for high protein you
know all of them made decisions visual I
mean that made the movies more
expressive
and pushed all the vocabulary in a
different way
to say we are not what we think you
think we are all the movies this year
it's a I think it's a landmark gear in
many many ways because everybody put
their butt on the line in some way or
another and it's paying off and and for
us it was
let's credit the animators up front
before the cast The Boys cast let's
treat them like that let's listen to
them let's watch them and and and let's
regain that stature that needs to be
regained for this to be an art form and
not an industrial assembly line
beautiful
uh thank you
I I I'm just going to put the red lights
on so I just want to I Just Want To
Praise these films
um you know one of the reasons I was
really really thrilled to be asked to
moderate this panel is um speaking of
the damn kovitz I was uh isolating at
home for the um nominee luncheon because
I wasn't able to go so I did not get to
meet and congratulate everybody on this
stage that day
um so congratulations to you all thank
you for elevating our the craft I'm
going to you know go out like Michio
prio from The Sopranos I have devoted my
life to this thing
and I could not be more honored and
thrilled to be stand to be sitting here
with so many creative folks who have
really pushed this art form who readily
pushed this medium yes animation is
often you know thought of as a kids
media medium
um but um you know the films on this
stage people go out and see
um and and they and they move people and
and people show them to their kids and
they watch them over and over again and
um I couldn't be prouder to be sitting
up here with her with you all and thank
you so so much for your amazing work for
pushing this craft and uh
congratulations thank you
thank you thanks everybody